good morning everyone uh
a couple of housekeeping items please
shut your phones
off or
put them on silence
if you uh
in the gallery want to have a discussion
with someone
you're welcome to do that i'm sure it's
important but please do it in the
hallway
um
i want to welcome all of the committee
members and
those of you who are substituting
for today i really appreciate you all
and with that i will ask
representative alessia to lead us in the
pledge of allegiance please
to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you all very much and with that i
will
i'll open this executive session
and we'll go over all these bills
um the first bill of the day is house
bill
1118 representative belanger do you have
a motion
i drew madam chair motion otp
do i hear a second
second
sorry
representative you kill a second that do
we have any discussion
hearing and seeing none
i will ask the clerk
to call the role
representative renzullo
no it would be
first
i apologize
representative yo keller
yes
representative
renzolo
yes
representative nelson
representative belanger
yes
representative healy
representative greene yes
representative denise smith
representative long yes representative
alessia
representative marjorie smith yes
representative levesque
yes representative chase
representative petrino i vote yes
and that is it
oh in the chair
and how does the chair vote yes i
apologize
thank you
with no objection uh representative long
has requested consent
i see no objections so we will put that
on consent
and thank you for that
our next bill is house bill
1278 relative to the modification or
termination of term alimony
um
representative nelson do you have a
motion thank you madam chair i do have a
motion my motion is to itl
do we have a second representative
belanger
second
we have a motion in a second
do we have any discussion
seeing none with the clerk please call
the role
representative yokela
yes
representative renzolo
representative nelson yes
representative belanger
yes representative healy yes
representative greene yes
representative denise smith
representative long yes representative
alicea
representative marjorie smith yes
representative levesque
yes representative chase
representative petrino i will be voting
yes
madam chair desimone
yes the vote is 14
to 0.
representative long has
requested consent
do i see
[Music]
any
representative chase
representative chase seconds that
without objection
this bill will go to consent thank you
representative chase and thank you
representative long
good morning representative altschuler
and welcome
yeah all rise
without objection we'll give
representative all chiller a minute to
get settled
all set representative
good
you're very welcome
the next bill will be house bill 1279
relative to the duration of term alimony
do i
hear a motion representative nelson yes
thank you madam chair i'm motion to itl
and do i hear a second
second
thank you representative belanger
will the clerk please call the roll
since i see no hands for discussion
representative yo keller
yes representative nelson
yes representative belanger
yes representative healey
yes representative greene yes
representative denise smith
representative long yes representative
alessa
representative marjorie smith yes
representative levesque yes
representative chase
representative altsula
yes
representative petrino i will be voting
madam chair desimone
yes
representative friend solo
oh representative renzolo i apologize
zero
representative long do i
representative long requests consent
without objection
representative alessia has seconded that
do i see any objection
consent it is
our next bill will be house bill 1280
prohibiting a parent's refusal
to vaccinate a child pursuant to an
order of the state or federal government
to be used as a basis for terminating
parental rights
do i hear a motion representative yokela
my motion otp
do we have a second
representative belanger
representative nelson
a second
thank you
representative
is there any discussion sure
representative long
thank you madam chair on uh
hospital 1280
uh
it's
plural the apparent decision there are
often times when parents don't agree
um
so i'm not sure how that would be
handled
and then the last line on line 12 has
the ultimate decision regarding the
health care of children resides with
parents
although i agree with that
i don't know if that statutorily changes
what we currently have
with respect to a divorce family
if a parent has the health care
responsibility
that this would change it to both
parents ultimate decision
on health care
so for that reason i'm i'm
i'm going to be supporting the itl
thank you representative long yo keller
would you like to speak to this bill
sure madam chair
um
listen this is my first day
you gotta give me a break here
it's um
so
i think that
really what we're
this is really only limited to the
termination of parental rights and so
i think that
it's only going to come up
in those hearings and
um so i
i did think that
um we had testimony that there was
someone that was you know maybe it was i
believe back in the 90s according to the
person that i talked to um that had some
their kids taken and put in foster care
i'm not sure if they were eventually um
terminated uh they didn't actually say
that but
um that was definitely concerning to me
and so
um i definitely don't want this to
happen and so even if it is not the
current practice i'd still be
um
supporting
making sure it doesn't happen in the
future so thank you
thank you representative yokela any
further discussion
representative smith
thank you very much
madam chairman i'm uh i'm puzzled
and perhaps
my colleague could
explain this to me a little more um he
refers to something that he had heard
that might or may not have happened in
the past
and
that usually is not the most reliable
information on which we should base
decisions
this committee
that i i've served on very briefly at
one point
but i have followed its work and the
committee has been
unbelievably careful
over the years of
recognizing
the rights of parents
in an intact marriage
and also
balancing the rights of parents when
marriages are no longer intact
and
trying to
balance
the incredibly the importance of the
rights of parents with obligations to
protect the well-being of the child
and
i've read the bill um i had been told
that there might be an amendment and i
was hopeful that there would be one but
there isn't and
based on the way the bill is written um
i think it undoes
a lot of the work that this committee
has has worked on so consistently over
the years
and i would hope that um
absent an amendment
that the committee
might consider
voting down the i t the otp motion and
perhaps instead going i'm sorry i'll
wait till you can
listen to me i'm sorry we are listening
to you
to the point where representative you
yokela has something to suggest
in uh maybe helping you
uh with your concerns i thank you what i
wish if i could just finish my sentence
what i was sure suggests it's that
perhaps
it might be appropriate at this time
for this bill to be referred to interim
studies so that it can
in fact honor the
long-time commitment of children and
family and also addressed what
is a
could be viewed as a specific problem
thank you very much madam chair
you're welcome thank you for your
concerns um
representative yokela would you like to
speak to uh
representative smith's concerns
um thank you um i
do so um
for your fur
in in regards to the um
the testimony that was brought to the
committee it was um
brought by a former uh employee of the
state and so
um i have no reason to believe that her
experience in that was was um
mistaken
um and i also
um do
remember mentioning um
that
i
would be open to an amendment on this um
specifically
removing the
as the ultimate decision regarding the
health care of the children resides with
the parents crossing that section of the
of the bill out and just saying a a
parent's decision to not have their
child vaccinated pursuant to an order of
the state or federal government or
agency or person of the same shall not
be grounds for termination of parental
rights period
might that address some of the concerns
that you
raised
well thank you very much for the
courtesy um representative
but um
whether it addresses or not is
irrelevant since my understanding is the
deadline on this bill um
would require us to vote on it now and
there is no amendment before us
one could be drafted
if it if it was the will of the the
committee
representative long
uh thank you madam chair i i mean i
would be more comfortable with
that
deletion
um
and i guess i could be okay with the
rest of the language although
you know it's going to be it's going to
be a court decision if both parents
don't agree with something
and we know how that works out
somebody's not happy and they come here
and let us know about it
but um but yeah i i i
having that last sentence
deleted would be helpful for me
would that bring
you to
agree with the ought to pass motion
representative
long oh wow
uh
i don't know what do you guys think
no no i guess not i guess not
thank you thank you uh representative
keller um i just wonder if um the
correction or the the amendment would
still be of enough value that we
um
we
postponed um until an amendment get
drafted later in this day that uh
that it be of enough value that we that
we not vote on it at this very moment
and wait for that amendment to be
drafted
or do you think that we should just move
forward
and and
um
maybe do a floor amendment or something
like that
is it true representative long that it's
not going to change your
motion
yes that's
that would be the truth
well with that said representative
yokela before i ask representative chase
for her question
uh i
if you want to make the amendment we can
do that if that amendment is important
to you
however it seems un
it seems that it's not going to change
the vote
in the i mean if you want to recognize
in the event of a expediency i think i
will um
just propose that amendment as a floor
amendment instead and so that i think
because i actually do think that the
changes of value so
um
so for that reason i i want it but i
don't want to hold up the committee
thank you representative i agree with
you
but i do want to hear representative
chase's concerns
actually it was more on the hearsay when
it might have been answered about
children being taken away from
parents because that they were not
going to vaccinate them
i didn't get to hear the whole testimony
i did listen
but um how how often does this happen
and
why was the concern of bringing this
bill forward just quick in a nutshell so
i can understand my vote thank you
um
yeah
according to the records it's happened
more than once and as far as
i'm concerned that's too many times
thank you
representative
oh are you finished
thank you representative belanger
uh thank you madam chair and i just
wanted to speak to the previous
representatives point um there was
actually a case this year where dcyf was
involved
in
a parent
choosing not to vaccinate their kiddo
i don't remember the exact name or
who that person was but i do recall that
being a case most recently this year
specifically
thank you representative any further
discussion or questions
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
representative yo keller
yes
representative nelson
yes representative balanger yes
representative
renzullo
representative healey
yes
representative greene yes
representative denise smith yes
representative long
representative
marjorie smith no
representative levesque no
representative chase no
representative
no representative petrino i will be
voting no
madam chair desimone
yes
motion carries 8-7
this will not go on consent
yes am i correct representative long
will there be a minority report
thank you
and your recommendation will be
thank you representative
okay
responsibilities
the next bill we will be discussing will
be uh house bill 1286 relative to the
modification of parental rights and
responsibility
uh representative yocala do you have a
motion emotion otp do we have a second
a second
representative yokela would you like to
speak to your motion
what is your motion sorry
um
i want to
withdraw my motion and and motion uh itl
sorry
thank you wrong page
you made representative long so happy
for a second
i'm sorry madam chair this is one two
eight six correct yes ma'am thank you
you're welcome do you want a second hat
jody
second
you withdraw your first second
i withdraw my first second
and you're going two seconds
and i'm seconding the second motion
thank you
thank you representative nelson
sorry
and did you want i want
you
want to speak to this motion
representative yokela yes um
the
uh
sponsor of the bill actually brought us
information that said that the supreme
court already interpreted the current
language
um
the way that she's planning to change it
so that it could be interpreted that
same way
and so
um the supreme court has already issued
guidance to all of the courts to that
this is how it should be interpreted and
so this change is
not
necessary thank you
any discussion
i saw representative all schiller's hand
first
thank you madam chair um
i am
i don't remember that particular bit of
uh testimony from the prime sponsor
however
what i do know from having spoken with
the prime sponsor is that there is
um a desire to have the legislation
match um and guide
future
um
future orders coming from the court
and this change of any of to only
actually provides a specific set of
bumpers if you will to keep
the decision
for modifying permanent orders
within a particular lane and to not
offer spaces for it to go left right and
sideways
so this was actually like a very very
specific ask to keep judicial constraint
within a specific lane
so i feel like it is incredibly
necessary thank you
thank you representative although
representative long you had
representatives
marjorie smith
thank you actually that was the point
that i was going to make that we have
over the years many times
we act as legislators we pass laws
the courts
face cases involving those laws they see
areas where perhaps we could
fine-tune the language in order to make
sure that intentions are clear in the
future
and
the usual procedure is to
evaluate that and
and agree and so i would have i was
delighted at the initial
motion
um
made a lot of sense and
now i'm confused
thank you
any further discussion
representative yokela
thank you madam chair so the supreme
court doesn't actually make laws they
just interpret it and so there was um
at some point there was a confusion
about the correct way to interpret it
but the supreme court clarified that
that
the correct way to interpret it is
that the list is limited and so
clarifying the language further
um just opens up to a new interpretation
by the supreme court of the language
and um
invites a lawsuit so i don't i don't
think so
i don't i don't agree so thank you matt
chair thank you
who's who's speaking
you are cause you're in charge
[Laughter]
who asked my
i did for my attention
representative smith
thank you um
it's
i'm a guest here and i understand that
and i don't want to
exceed my authority
but
i listened to my colleague speak and
what he said
supports
um
his initial
uh
his initial motion and that is in fact
the you know we make the laws
the court looks at them
the court doesn't make the laws but they
say we're there there's a need to
clarify
that should be
the legislators responsibility
so that we can clarify and put in place
what we want and i know that sometimes
we get attached to one bill or another i
certainly have over the years
but or one position or another but i
think
his initial instinct was right and i'd
like to go back to that first motion at
some point thank you
thank you for your suggestion
any further discussion
representative altschiller thank you
madam chair um
i'd like to um
i'd like to say that representative
yokela's initial motion was right on the
money because um
as you said it's the supreme it's the
court it's the judicial
judicial grants branches responsibility
to interpret
the laws
and when the judicial branch sees that
there are is confusion it it is often
and regularly brought before us
to
clean up to clarify
and to
fine-tune
spaces where in the law has question
so while the supreme court may
have ruled in a space that
perhaps in one representative's opinion
makes this moot
um i would say that it would do no harm
for your argument to
make the motion of ought to pass so that
the clarification
can be put in statute
to to make sure that we don't have to do
exactly
what the courts have asked us to do
which is often clarify
consolidate and make more concise
the intent
of the law so
we're all on the same page i think i
think we're all on the same page and um
thank you respectfully would ask for a
withdrawal of your motion
um of itl to otp so we can all be on the
same page together thank you
representative yokala do you have
yes
in
sometimes when we write laws they are
vague
and the
the question goes to the supreme court
for clarification
and
sometimes the courts
do
rule in such a way that they do not
um
that the legislature
they rule in such a way that
the legislature may not agree
with their ruling and therefore the
legislation comes to clarify the
language so that
that that ruling
um which the legislature believes is
incorrect couldn't be clarified and be
pointed in the in the correct direction
but in this case
the legislature said what they thought
was
the the um or they made the law
then
a
lower court
interpreted in one way and the supreme
court says no you're wrong that this is
the correct way and that is the way that
that this bill is proposed and so
there is no there was once confusion
by a lower court but there's no longer
any confusion that it is a limited list
by both what we've said in the law
currently
and what the supreme court interpreted
our language to be
so there is
so this law
is just um
not necessary in the sense that it's
already been clarified
and so i agree that it the purpose
whether we pass this bill or we don't
pass this bill the policy is the exact
same
for the for the state of new hampshire
so i don't think that um in a time that
we're having a uh you know uh overflow
of bills
that uh
that we need to
pass laws or have additional hearings
about laws that are not actually going
to change policy in new hampshire
thank you
thank you representative
that said i see no from the hands i'll
ask the clerk to
call the roll
representative yokela
yes
representative renzullo
representative nelson
yes representative belanger yes
representative healey yes representative
green yes representative denise smith
representative long no representative
alicea
representative marjorie smith
no representative levesque
no representative chase
representative
no representative petrino i will be
voting no
madam chair
yes
the vote is eight to seven
will you be
uh
turning in a minority report
representative long
will anybody yes
representative all chiller okay thank
you
the motion is otp right
representative all chiller what will
your motion be in your report
is going to be otp right okay thank you
thank you i'm giving everybody a second
to get caught up
thank you um
next i will
accept an emotion i'm sorry
a motion
on house bill 1305 relative to temporary
alimony
representative yokela do you have a
motion
yes i motion otp
do i hear a second i second
representative nelson seconds that for
representative yo keller would you like
to speak to your motion
yes i i uh agree with this bill that
that um
that temporary alimony should be
calculated the same way as
regular alimony i'm not sure why there
is ever a difference and um
i think that
um
the time
pay spent paying the alimony should
count towards the time being spent
uh
allowed for the total amount time uh
spending
uh
paying alimony so i think that this is
uh a good bill thank you
thank you representative keller any
discussion
representative long
uh thank you madam chair i i uh we all
received an email from uh
journey hastings who's been in this
field forever who's has an attorney
family
courts and has a mediator
um
i i think this opens up for example
i think this opens up
um
i mean the alimony has only been placed
uh within the past i want to say
five years maybe four years
i don't have i printed out an email i
don't have it on me uh so
so i think changing it it's it's my
understanding that's been working i
don't know
what this addresses um
i was here
for the testimony and they're they're
just the introduction from
representative d simone
um
so i i don't know
i don't know where this helps
and i think it has the potential to uh
hurt with respect to temporary
you know somebody
i don't know if this if this addresses
uh when somebody
is getting alimony and goes into a
relationship or gets a remarried
ends up in a divorce
comes back
after six months and they still have
three years of the prior alimony
uh would that kick in are those
addressed are those addressed in this
belt
sure
um i don't believe that they are within
the scope of this bill and um i i just
wonder why we have the calculation the
normal calculation for alimony and then
an additional
uh temporary calculation which does not
need to use the normal calculation
like what what is the purpose of having
the calcul like why can't they just use
the calculation that's my question
and that would have that was the purpose
for the bill
thank you
uh representative although do you have a
question or discussion
oh
thank you
any further discussion
see none i will ask the clerk to call
the role
representative yo keller
yes
representative renzolo
representative nelson
yes representative belanger yes
representative healey yes representative
greene yes representative denise smith
yes representative long no
representative alicea
excuse me i apologize i said
representative all the say i meant to
say
alsa i apologize
representative
marjorie smith no representative
levesque
no representative chase
representative altschuler
no representative petrino i'll be voting
no madam chair desimone yes
the vote is eight to seven
will it be a minority report
back okay
thank you
next we'll open
house bill
relative to the presumption of shared
parenting in the determination of
parental rights and responsibilities
representative yokela do i hear a motion
i motion
otp
do i hear a second for that motion
representative bolander
thank you madam chairs is the
um
is representative ellen not bringing
forward his amendment
he will once we
get through the otp motion
sorry
i i i apologize i've never been on a
committee where you don't first vote on
the amendment and then we will
but
that's okay thank you
representative yo keller
thank you i would like to move uh
amendment
2022-087-h
and you should all have a copy of that
amendment
um
and now i'll ask for a second
can you use your words thank you
listen
representative belanger has seconded
the motion
on the amendment
7h
representative keller would you like to
speak to your motion
yes thank you
this amendment just
wipes out the entire
bill and replaces it with
a definition of shared parenting
where each parent plays substantially
equal role in decision making and 35
percent or more of the child's
residential time is spent with each
parent and then it also
places inside of the parental rights and
responsibilities where
under section
i
dash a
there is a um
a section that reads that if the court
concludes that frequent and continuing
contact between each child and both
parents is not in the best interest of
the child the court shall make finding
supporting that order and so
um
all we're doing is adding the language
that if the court doesn't make that
conclusion that there should be a
presumption that shared parenting is in
the best interest of the child so there
is still um
kind of judicial leeway as far as um one
deciding
that
uh
the
contact between both parents is not in
their best interest
and
um you know even in the current uh law
right now we
we
already recognize that that
contact if if the you know there's no
harm to the child in doing so that
contact between both parents
um is best and all that and a bunch of
research that i'm aware of suggest that
that is best for the um
the social and emotional
um
relationships uh
that that child
that uh
forms
in their in their youth is is beneficial
by contact with both parents if they're
not harming their ch
child and so i believe that this makes
it clear that um
that the the court can still say that
it's not the best interest of the child
if there's if there's reason to but
otherwise we should try and um
move towards
both parents being uh
a significant part of that child's life
so
i
uh hope that you will support this this
amendment thank you
thank you any discussion sure
representative long
thank you madam chair so so
although i do agree with the
representative that both parents are the
best case scenario
uh that's not often the reality
uh the current customized parenting
schedule approach appears that will be
gone
and this is important where there's more
than two children involved because there
may be
a parental schedule that suits one and
may not suit the other
uh so i i think this
i i think this is rigid as far as the
scheduling goes it's
uh i know
i know you also say if the court does
not make that conclusion so the court
would have to make that conclusion
that they could put it back to a
customized um
to a current scheduling
that is current is that
is that what that last sentence says
thank you um
i
um
so currently they're already making that
determination this is already in law
right where they can determine that um
that the child should not be with one of
the parents
and um
the the um the language added is just
that there shall be a presumption
obviously if there is evidence that that
is not the case then
the presumption would be overturned
right
so follow up for me
follow up yeah so so the um
so what what changes the court needs the
judge needs to put in writing
or something to where i mean i'm trying
to figure out what what changes with
this being passed
it doesn't appear that anything's
changed
thank you representative yokela thank
you for the question um
so the
[Music]
the
the change is if they don't believe that
it's going to be harmful to the kid to
have relationships with both parents
that their starting point
should be that they have relationships
with both kids in a significant amount
of time and not just like one day every
month or you know one weekend a month
kind of a thing it would be more
substantial than that unless they have
reason
to
say otherwise
okay
thank you
thank you representative altschiller
thank you madam chair
my deep concern
in
establishing um
my deep concern is that this is a um
this this is a
very
subtle but impactful
impactful
place um where
this is not about the best interests of
the child but the best interests of the
parents
and i'm i'm very concerned
that
for
families that experience domestic
violence
that this
creates a space
that
there is a presumption that shared
parenting is in the best interest of the
child and we know
from
court decisions that have been made that
decisions that affect
to adults relationships
often
hurt the children involved
and that
i think that this
creates a space where the parents
um conflicts
will take precedence over the best
interests of the child i don't see a
carve out i don't see any
acknowledgement that um that this is
about the children it says mostly this
is mostly about the rights of
of parents and not about
the the best interest of the child
so if
representative yoko if you could explain
how this protects children
in the spaces where domestic violence
happens um
i just i want to understand this better
thank you representative keller would
you care to respond
i would just point you to lines 11 and
12 of the of the amendment
thank you
any further discussion
representative all chiller thank you
very much um i can i read 11 and 12 but
it doesn't
that doesn't answer my question which is
how
it this is it's incredibly vague
doesn't address
domestic violence in any meaningful or
significant way
um
doesn't mention
abuse it doesn't mention
you know
convictions it doesn't mention
restraining orders it doesn't it's just
very vague so i don't understand how
that particular language is protective
and thank you
does it refer to another space in law
that i am missing because i have 461a up
and i just
thank you
any further discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
voting on the amendment
representative that's correct
representative
yes
representative renzolo
representative nelson
yes representative belanger yes
representative healey yes representative
greene yes representative denise smith
yes representative long
yes representative alessa
representative elisa
i apologize i'm having such a difficult
time i'm rereading it and rereading it i
apologize to the committee
um you can come back to okay all right
would you like the clerk to come back to
you representative yes please certainly
representative marjorie smith
yes representative levesque
yes
representative chase yes
representative altschuler
no
representative
petrino i will be voting yes
elisa
madam chair
yes okay
13 to 2
the amendment
passes
representative yokela do you have a
motion
i move otpa
is there a second to that motion
representative belanger
seconds
thank you
any just further discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
representative
yes
representative nelson
yes representative renzolo
representative belanger yes
representative healy yes representative
greene yes representative denise smith
yes representative long no
representative alicea
representative marjorie smith no
representative levesque no
representative chase no
representative
nope
representative petrino i will be voting
no
madam chair desimone yes
the vote is eight to seven
will there be a minority report
and what will your motion be in that re
report it'll be itl
thank you representative long uh
representative al tiller
yes madam chair
i apologize i was just alerting
representative ocala that you will in
fact be writing the minority report
indeed thank you you're welcome
okay
that is being addressed immediately
thank you
i am too with no disrespect to anybody
i'm putting my hands over here and
yeah
okay can we have some order here and
we'll go on to the next bill please
the next bill is house bill 1396
fn relative to the payment of child
support
uh
representative uh nelson
do you have a motion yes thank you madam
chair um motion to itl
do i have a second second manager
representative belanger seconds
representative nelson's
motion
representative nelson would you like to
speak to that motion ma'am
no thank you
do i see any discussion representative
long
thank you madam chair the the um
we we've heard
testimony and received documents with
respect to um
the court will will say that element
um that um child support is owed at a
hundred dollars a week
uh effective uh 11
11 1
and then we're hearing of
people receiving the support not
receiving the support
and taking not receiving the support for
two or three or sometimes four weeks
until they go back to court
because the person that's supposed to be
paying
says it wasn't defined
when i'm supposed to pay i was supposed
to pay november first and that's all i
paid uh it doesn't say i got to pay
every week after
uh i mean
that's the fact that's happening now so
this is a simple fix
that when the judge makes the decision
put in the payment schedule
every every beginning of the week
effective november 1st
or or what have you that is currently
going on now that people are supposed to
be receiving this child support are not
receiving it they're waiting to go back
to court to get the judge to give a
schedule
and that's hurting people that ought to
be
receiving their child support in a
timely manner
i'm sorry thank you any further
discussion
representative chase
thank you very much madam chair and
representative long i think you know my
ex-husband
so this is a perfect
this is great because that was always
the the clarification so i'm going to
agree with this this i thought i'd like
this bill i think it's
clarifies exactly when there are some
many good good parents out there who pay
and take care of their children but
there are also those others that well it
wasn't said and i'm going to pay when i
want to or you're going to have to keep
dragging me back to court
that is a real issue with child care
while you have to go to court to try to
get the little bit of money that's
supposed to be paying for these kids and
my own personal experience i love this i
think it's a great bill thank you
thank you representative al shiller
thank you very much um
i at the risk
of dating myself a little bit
used to be a time when you would make a
purchase take out a loan have a
financial responsibility that came along
with it a set of stubs that you would
fill in the date write a check stick
that stub in it had it had a number on
it that would refer to the payment that
you owed in whatever venue it was and we
don't do that anymore
however uh particularly it would be
super helpful in the courts because we
heard testimony and we know
that
without very clear and explicit
instructions we have a significant
number of granite staters who
will look for any and all loopholes to
not pay
what they owe
for their child support so um this would
give a specific
time frame that child support is due on
a specific date
um and when it doesn't come through that
gives the person who is supposed to be
getting that child support to pay for
those children an opportunity to go to
court
and say a deadline has been missed
without having to get involved with all
the nonsense that is happening right now
with people who are supposed to be
paying saying well it wasn't really
clear
we couldn't be more clear if we just put
in a payment schedule thank you
thank you any further discussion
representative ocala
thank you and thank you for recognizing
me um
i agree that it is a good practice
um
i
however have concerns that one
that
if someone's situation is
fluid
they're
they may be
looking for a job or in between jobs
that payment
let's say on the 15th and the 30th of
the month may not be appropriate in the
new situation and
the courts may have to hear
a case to try and change the due date
and so i believe that while it's good
practice there's nothing barring the
courts from doing
this now
by saying that and it leaves all open
the option for them to not specify it
in cases where it is
it that specifying it would only create
more work for them in the future so
i
agree that it's good practice
but i'm not sure that legislating it is
the best solution
thank you
representative petrino
thank you madam chair um regarding this
discussion
uh tia to your point uh uh
representative also
if you have car payments to make the
bank expects that you make your payment
regardless of whether or not you can pay
or not
and really child support is much more
important than making monthly car
payments
so that's just my two cents on that
matter
thank you uh representative long
thank you madam chair so
uh if you lose your job or you just got
your wages knocked down you notify the
court so that you notify the court right
away so the court knows that why this
payment didn't come in
uh and also uh
you know again we're looking at the i
you know i'm getting mixed messages just
the world according to me or this
committee according to me
um judges discretion which some bills we
absolutely do not want the judges to
have the discretion and then some bills
well leave it up to the judge's
discretion
um you know so
you know and i think
the court system i've heard this before
probably
uh when they came before us an
organizational day that they preferred
that the legislation be clear
you know that that's what they prefer
because it's you know and it makes sense
to me if i'm a judge
which
i don't qualify whatsoever but if i was
i would like to be clearer with with
legislation and not having it
interpreted so
you know in this case to having the
judge's discretion i i
this is a simple
why not you know
why not make it statutory
required
thank you uh representative bellinger
and then representative smith
uh thank you madam chair for recognizing
me i think one of the things that i've
recognized in this committee is that
we hear all sorts of situations when it
comes to child support there's there's
no
set scenario that is perfect
when
the issue that i have
is that
these things should be worked out in the
courtroom it shouldn't be a requirement
that you have to pay it on this day at
this time
it should be a payment
but unfortunately
i think this bill is just
not the best
and i think it can be done a little bit
better
which is why i support the itl motion
thank you representative smith
thank you very much
i cannot tell you how much i am
valuing my experience here with this
committee today because
i learned so much from seeing how other
committees function
but i have to admit that i'm confused
in that
again going back to something that
representative outsole said i'm old
enough to remember a song that said
first you say you do and then you don't
first you say you will and then you
won't
and what i hear is agreement about the
importance of child support
the
importance of
of having a court make a reasonable
rational decision
about how that child support should be
paid
and then the music stops because then
what i hear is
someone or another saying well yes the
court makes the decision and they say it
should be paid every week or every two
weeks or every month and it should be
this much
but
if that's not what happens so it's
what doesn't happen
requiring then
the
aggrieved parent to go back to court
and to start all over again and
if we all agree that
i mean i won't tell you my principle
that nobody in the world should be
allowed to have children unless i agreed
that they in fact would be good parents
but i'm going to let that one go i mean
you know just for the moment i'm going
to let that one go
but things happen and marriages break up
after children have arrived on the scene
the state has a responsibility for the
well-being of those children and we have
a court system
to enforce that and when the court says
a b and c
that ought to be the rule and if
circumstances change and they do people
lose a job or they get a job that's
going to require them to move out of
state or all kinds of other things
happen
you then can go back to court and say
please
revisit
the decision because the circumstances
have changed
and if the circumstances haven't changed
well then you ought to follow the court
and on this one again i hope
that
i i'm i'm so upset
i'm always upset when i see partisan
votes i just don't see things in a
partisan way i never ran a committee's
partisan
and i see people
questioning things that are said but
still voting in a way that they think
maybe they're expected to i'd like
perhaps this one to be a bill
since we have consensus of the
importance of supporting
children which is what child support is
about
that we recognize that we ought to make
it easy to be able to
in to know what's expected and to have
expect people to follow what's expected
and so i hope we might
not accept the pending motion and in
fact recognize that this bill does what
i think we all want to have happen thank
you madam
thank you
representative also thank you madam
chair my concern is i just feel like it
it reads as in the interest of the
parent
so do you say to your child
the parent that's supposed to pay
isn't able there's no schedule for for
your other parent to pay
therefore i can't schedule dinner today
so i'm having a hard time i apologize
again
we're all here for children
and it just feels like
we're making it comfortable
for adults
that's a
statement thank you okay thank you
representative alzheimer thank you very
much madam chair so i'm i think
i am also deeply uncomfortable
um because we have
we have rules and we have laws in the
state of new hampshire about paying our
bills and paying them on time
and um if for instance you take out you
are you owe money on a car and you don't
pay that money on the car
you can have that car taken away in less
than 90 days 90 days and there is firm
action but if you don't pay your child
support
you can be in arrears for more than a
year
you can be in arrears for over ten
thousand dollars
before the courts
take swift action and i would say that
one year is not necessarily
swift action
there are spaces where the court
can put a withholding
on a paycheck
and i will
i will i will say that i have worked
with parents
for whom their
the parent
of their the other parent of their child
specifically stays underemployed or
works for money under the table so
there's nothing to report and then
claims i don't have any money and also
they also don't have a schedule that
they have to pay on because their first
payment was due on december 1st
and then it says nothing about
when the actual next payment is due so
we go through
um
the the parents who are paying for their
children's
diapers and medicines and shoes and
the rent on the apartment and the heat
are left twisting in the wind because we
have negligent parents who are using
these loopholes that we can just close
up super easy right now
to jump through which
no other
financial
obligation
would allow for not one in this state so
i would hope that we can pass this to
protect the parents who are trying to
care for their children
they can't as representative alicea said
say we're just you know
we're not going to have wi-fi i know you
have home school this week but we're not
having it because we don't have enough
money um thank you
so
yeah
thank you
any further discussion
representative yokela
thank you um
and uh
i believe the previous representative
hit
um the nail right on the head that the
problem isn't
that the courts
can or cannot or should or should not
put the due date in the system the
problem is enforcement
and when enforcement
is happening and so i absolutely agree
that a bill which
maybe
does not allow
for
a year of arrears and ten thousand
dollars before we do anything about it
is
to change that to a lower amount or 90
days or whatever i believe that is um
cutting right at the heart of this issue
whereas i don't believe it's actually
the judge's fault
for lack of clarity that the payments
are not coming in
but
the i believe in fact that you kind of
have pointed out that the
their their hands are tied because
they're not able to enforce it until
far
past when it should be enforced and so i
think that this is
not
the solution
but i
i agree that uh
a bill addressing the the
the ability to go a year or ten thousand
dollars is something that
the legislature should address going
forward thank you thank you
representative chase uh madam chair i
apologize but i did have my hand raised
i apologize i did not see it
representative
i will ask you to um
after
to
representative yokela saw me with my
hand raised i'm sorry i did not
but i will uh entertain your discussion
after representative chase whom i've
already called on
representative
belanger
you have thank you i apologize madam
chair i thought the representative
to your right had mentioned something so
um the two previous speakers ago
mentioned that um you
90 days your car car
payment company your bank might
repossess your car but one of the things
that you can do is contact the bank
and ask them hey i can't make my payment
this week
i need to postpone that payment
so
i'm not disagreeing that child care
payments should
we should close the loopholes i just i
agree with representative yokela when we
say that the enforcement is the problem
now if i have to pay my child care
payment on the 15th and have not
had it removed from my check by my
employer which as an employer i have an
employee who does um have that withdrawn
because of that reason
and they're not doing their
responsibility to make sure that it's
being done which is their responsibility
to do but i can't make the payment on
the 15th because i'm working paycheck to
paycheck
and i have to go and file every time
with the court just becomes a redundancy
so i'm just going to go back to what the
previous speaker said representative
ocala about the
enforcement of the problem and i just
again support this itl motion and i hope
we can all find a better solution as we
continue to move forward through this
legislative session thank you
representative chase
thank you madam chair
it just it's it is a step in the right
direction i completely agree and
understand what everybody's saying i i
first handed went through this for years
with my children and having to drag my
ex-husband back to court i understand
how much more it cost me i know the fact
of not being able to do things for my
children because i didn't have the funds
because their father wasn't holding up
his end of the deal
all this is is just adding a
a structured payment plan so that person
says oh okay this is when i need to have
this done and it's written and i feel it
very strongly because i he had his wages
garnished as well
that i could have gone back into court
and just said here's the schedule and
this is what he's doing and this is what
he's missed and have him be held
accountable for it
it's so simple and i do agree about the
other changes in a loss i think that's
something that would be great for
somebody to bring forward in the next
session
i just
don't see itling this at all thank you
thank you representative petrino yeah
thank you very much
every month we have bills to pay and we
prioritize what's most important so i
have to decide whether or not i pay my
rent if i pay my cable if i pay for my
wi-fi my car payment first and foremost
the first thing that i
pay for should be my child
and so even though my circumstances may
change for months a month in terms of my
income
i still have all these bills to pay
what's the first bill that should be
paid pay for my child make sure that kid
eats that's my first responsibility my
cell phone that's secondary
okay so
again
children first
thank you representative i will now
ask
representative petrino our clerk to call
the role
thank you madam chair
representative
yo keller
yes
representative renzolo
representative nelson
yes
representative belanger yes
representative healy
yes representative greene yes
representative denise smith yes
representative long no
representative alessia
representative marjorie smith no
representative levesque no
representative chase no representative
altula
no representative petrino i will be
voting no
madam chair de simone yes
eight to seven
will there be a minority report
who will write the minority report
representative long and what will your
motion be
no that is the motion
thank you i think you should we would
agree
and on that note we'll begin um
house bill 1416 which it looks like we
may agree
would you yes
now we'd probably do a group hug before
this one
kumbaya
uh representative yochella do you have a
motion my motion otp
would you like to speak oh do i have a
second
representative nelson seconds that
representative yokela would you like to
speak to that motion i i uh
motion that we adopt uh amendment
2022-081-h
it's nice to know that you can make
mistakes too
sorry about that that was for the wrong
bill
um
yes motion uh 20 22 uh
2022-0871 h
and would you like to
do we have a second on that second
seconded by representative nelson and
would you like to speak to that motion
representative keller
thank you
um my my uh my amendment just changes
the
the phrase um
within 30 days
after or
within 30 days and changes it to before
treatment begins
and uh
the
there was
definitely concern in my part that
someone may
get that treatment
uh
and then the person paying for that
treatment may find out
about that treatment only by or by the
bill before it was ever required to
be
you know mentioned to that person
and so
i thought that that was just going to
create additional tension and that you
know we
even in emergencies you could reach out
and tell the other person that that
you're on the way to getting treatment
and so
i believe that this
um will reduce acrimony um while still
reaching that same goal of trying to
get that
child services as as soon as possible
thank you
thank you representative do we have any
discussion
sing none
i will uh ask
the clerk to call the role
on the amendment
representative yokela
yes
representative nelson
yes representative renzolo
representative belanger
no
representative healy
yes
representative green yes
representative smith yes
representative long yes
representative alessia
representative marjorie smith
yes
representative levesque yes
representative chase yes
representative altschuler
yes representative petrino i will be
voting yes madam chair desimone
yes
14 to 1 on the amendment
do i hear a motion from representative
yokela
i move otpa
do i have a second on that motion
second
that's seconded by representative nelson
do i have any discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
representative yokela
yes
representative renzolo
representative nelson
yes representative belanger
no
representative healy
yes representative green yes
representative denise smith
representative long yes
representative alessa
representative marjorie smith yes
representative levesque
yes representative chase yes
representative altula
yes
representative petrino i will be voting
madam chair desimone i'll be voting yes
fourteen to one
uh can it go on consent it has a fiscal
note
okay right right thank you
um without objection this bill
representative belanger objects
therefore will not go on consent
do you want to do a report yes ma'am
okay
i'm just waiting for the clerk
next we i will hear a motion on house
bill
establishing the parental bill of rights
representative yo keller do you have a
motion by motion otp
do i hear a second second manager
seconded by representative belanger
representative yokela would you like to
speak to that motion yes i'd like to
move amendment
2022-0881h
do i hear a second on that second madam
chair
representative uh belanger seconds that
motion
and representative yo keller would you
like to speak to your
motion
sure um
this
uh amendment
uh
was worked on um
to um clean up what i and
some in our committee
i worked with this with representative
nelson
and
we had some concerns with the language
that i'm sure were were apparent at the
hearing
and um i believe
some of those
um are bet were best um
served by uh kind of reducing the scope
of this bill
um
because there was too many um
too many issues to
try and get right all in one
shot and so
my hope is that reducing the issues make
this bill tighter and cleaner and
reduce the
the conflicts
and the hope of getting this um
positive uh recommendation
and
uh
the main thing that uh
we wanted to do was to remove um
the
the medical
uh languages because we've we believe
that that was um
that most of the testimony that we heard
about the issues in the state were
regarding actual schools
and
not
as much about the medical
issues and so i believe that we have the
time to get the medical issues right
before moving forward with that and
there's also
a concern of people being able to go to
jail or
so we were moved in the violation
yeah we removed the um
the class a misdemeanor to a class b
misdemeanor which does not have any um
jail penalty possibility
and also removed the
removal of
the teaching credentials for a year and
remove that to just
say that they would get a
disciplinary letter in their personnel
file and not
for any uh teacher school employee or
administrator that violates the
provisions of this so
for the mo
and and also we clarified that the as
far as obtaining records
the record requests which should be
going to the superintendent
and they would be responding in 10
business days
and
that's actually longer i believe than
the
91a
uh
so that should not be a problem
and um
i i'll
i think that hopefully
i'll i'll try and uh do more
clarification if if uh it's needed thank
you
thank you do i see any discussion
representative long
thank you madam chair uh
yeah this this um
we had a good hearing i i listened and
uh the representative's absolutely
correct
i heard from all the testimony maybe one
sentence of health care the rest was on
education
um so i think
in in my opinion i you know throughout
the hearing and
trying to swallow this
you know i'm thinking when were
parental rights taken away
i
i keep having a hard time getting that
clear in my mind
i looked through some of the town
meeting warrants
these same issues are on warrants at our
meetings
i think that's the way to go
manchester for example all that they
were looking for is on the website there
are other municipalities that have that
on the website so it's not a state as a
whole
uh you know every municipality in the
state as a whole that we're fixing here
it's specific to
it's specific to some districts that for
whatever reason aren't giving people
what they ought to be given people that
is currently in statute when you look at
uh thank you miss dwyer for
dyer for the uh
the side by side
so
so i don't know what this is going to do
putting it in statute again
it seems like it's going to be the same
issue and then i also have an issue with
uh
page 1 line 18
through 23 and then 25 to 26.
so i'll give you an example
as has a parent somebody put in a
complaint that my child was being uh
abused
so dcyf comes to visit me
i don't allow him in because this is my
right i got parental rights this is my
right
you prove to me that my child's being
abused even though the child is being
abused
you prove to me that there's abuse and
then you could take that child but right
now with these parental rights no you
can't you do the investigation and you
show me where
there's abuse and then i'll
uh and then i'll comply if if i even
will
um so so i do have an issue with that so
i i think this is
with respect to the schools this is for
the schools
to decide
uh and and
the infringement on parental rights
prohibits
any political subdivision
then it names off uh and then also the
parent of a minor child in this state
without obstruction or interference with
the state and again this is apparent
it's singular it's not plural so
in a healthy home where there's both
parents what if one disagrees
who's
who has the parental rights
you know uh you know which
i mean we heard in testimony somebody
recommended we go to court
again let's send everybody to court
uh and we know what happens there so
thank you madam chair
you're welcome thank you and
representative belanger
uh thank you madam chair and i had some
of the similar
for recognizing me sorry so i had some
of the similar concerns that the
previous speaker
had which is why i had requested that
on page three
lines 36 through 37 specifically include
rsa 169 c which is the um
abuse and neglect statute so it says
authorize a parent of a minor child this
chapter does not
specific emphasis on not
authorize a parent of a minor child in
this state to engage in conduct that is
unlawful or to abuse or neglect his or
her minor child in violation of general
law as defined in rsa 169 c
so i think for me
this
satisfies my concerns
and i support the otp motion
thank you representative smith
thank you madam chair um
following up with representative long
um
i had that happen to me
i have a child with disabilities and
the principal of her school
called dcyf on us and we didn't have a
choice to let dcyf in our house
my child has separation anxiety
and she had missed several days of
school
several meaning 70.
um
and
i i can't get her to school some days
and i literally i'm the mother that
leaves her kids screaming in the parking
lot
and leaves there crying hysterically
that i'm the worst mother in the world
but my child has disabilities and
this principal had no right to call dcyf
she did not
speak to anyone
on my daughter's iep team
she just looked at her attendance
schedule and called dcyf
and
when we went to discuss this with her
her option to get my daughter to school
was to call the police
and have the police come and help her
get to school
she was six
at the time
so needless to say this does happen and
this happens to good
parents and i got the letter that said i
am a good parent because she dismissed
the case
but it does happen
and it was awful
thank you thank you for taking my
question any further representative long
thank you madam chair and and i
absolutely i do believe it does happen i
i've heard several from my constituents
where it was unfair i get that
but on this committee we got to look at
the 20 000
at the 20 000 uh
oh i thought that's oh
well you guys aren't getting 20 grand to
be here
uh yeah
at the 20 only you and i represented at
the 20 000 at the 20 000 l you know
level
and
although bad things happen to good
parents
what i'm more concerned about is bad
things happen
happening to children because of bad
parents
um you know so that's what i try to look
at
is there some incidental
uh what do they call it uh you
know collateral damage type of stuff
um
i you know i
i look at one child being harmed
i'm i'm on that page
uh so
uh and with respect to um
with respect to the language of 169c
these are both 169i
so i don't know if that would go to this
i don't think it would
yeah
on first page 18 and
25 24
169 i4 and i3
and then we're referencing uh does not
this chapter does not
authorize uh has defined in 169c
so is that a misprint
no
169c is where the
um they define
abuse and neglect
and that's where you get your rights
terminated all of that is in 169
c
169 i is a new
section that we're adding right now
okay
okay so
so with respect follow-up
a follow-up for me
certainly
the the um
with respect to the uh
the state or any of its political
subdivisions
that does not affect
that does that does not affect uh when
it comes to abuse and neglect is that
what you're saying
representative yokela would you like to
respond thank you um so i would just
point you to all of the exceptions not
just that one on um
on the end of uh page three but it
continues on page four that says it does
not prohibit the court of competent
jurisdiction law enforcement officers
employees of the government agency that
is responsible for child welfare from
acting in his official capacity within
reasonable improv prudent scope of his
earth her authority
or prohibit the court from issuing
orders that otherwise permit permitted
by law including limits on some or all
of the items listed in this chapter as
justice may require
so there's i believe that there is
a lot of latitude for the um
the
law enforcement or
child welfare protection to be able to
still do what they need to do
with this um those exceptions uh
being explicitly stated
okay thank you follow if i may just
follow up
uh so
when it says um
so 169 i3 and i4
is not the fact
it shall not infringe doesn't mean it's
any political subdivision shall not
infringe is not the case
right and i think that's what we were
hearing
in testimony
is what
the people i testified wanted
but now
we we have these two adding these two
sections
however waving
police
dcyf
i mean is that what we're doing
representative yokela
thank you for the question so
um this bill is not intended to give
parents like carte blanche to do
whatever they want right this is this is
this bill um is
a mechanism to one uh encourage
the
schools to have a continued dialogue
with
parents and
that
they are not
um
so you don't have a fundamental right
right to harm your children
or
any other crime against the children or
anything that's not
currently allowed and this this
chapter
says
that it is not authorizing parents to
engage in unlawful conduct so i don't
believe that this is this is opening up
and giving exceptions to things that are
currently not allowed it's just
clarifying um so that parents have um
a place to look at where
like
what options that they do have and it
encourages them especially because
you're talking about like schools um
trying to post stuff online they're um
in the 1695 there is
essentially a directive that the school
boards
have policies regarding
the options of these parents and then um
it also requires that they have
procedures
um for a parent to learn about the
additional
uh things that they have in statute
options that they have in statute
including access to the instructional
material and and such so it's more of
encouraging them to
have a policy and have a have think
about how they're going to disseminate
or
either disseminate the information and
or educate the parents that they
have these uh
these the ability to you know they have
the choice here and that they are free
to exercise
it and i i
and so that is really the the
the thing uh that i see of value in this
and not that it's giving them more
rights than they currently have now but
making sure you know just like we um you
know uh have the right to remain silent
we still tell the people they have the
right to remain silent when we arrest
them it's not
that they didn't have it before we told
them right we just started reminding
them hey you have this opportunity to
exercise it right so thank you for the
question
thank you
madam chair
representative
alessia thank you very much um
representative yokela i understand i
think representative can you move the
mic a little closer we want to hear what
you say
thank you
can you hear me better now yes thank you
representative
i think i understand what you're trying
to say
i was on the school board for 19 years
eight of those years as a policy chair
and on our website
every single policy that we put forth
included information about parental
rights
and every
anything that you could think of
was on there
and in the committees
once we would go through how we felt
about dealing with the children and the
policies we would then underneath write
what the parents could
do what their rights were and
after 19 years
i mean i was at every meeting
we never had
a parent come in and say you know you
didn't
let me come and speak to the teacher or
i wasn't part of the iep or
you know something negative they were
always offered and it's written and
there's a book like that
that big with all the policies not just
for the children
but for the parents as well
so
i'm wondering if
if we do this
does that take away from the
the districts
that are doing their own
policies
i mean we worked really hard
to do the right thing
for both the children and the parents
so
how would that affect
each district
thank you for the question um
i am happy to hear that that your your
district is already doing um this stuff
so in in the language the only
requirement is that they have a policy
it's not dictating the method of saying
um you have to post it on the website
and you guys are providing it you know
in the library or something like that
there's no requirement that you post
something or it's just that the paul
that the the board should consider
um this and have this issue and create a
policy for it and if and
by your testimony it seems like the the
district that you're that you were a
part of already was following those best
practices and
and had positive effects and so um i
think that it's possible that this
legislation if passed may have no effect
on your um
your district at all it would only
encourage the other
districts that may not have such a um
well
um
like um a well like exp
no no um i was saying like expand
expansive amount of policies regarding
um the opportunities of parents to
um be
or comprehensive yeah
yes comprehensive robust i'm getting a
lot of a lot of help
robust amount of
policies
that explain the parents ability or
encourage the parents ability to
take an active part in the person the
their child's education
and
i uh
i mean in the testimony it seemed like
that is not the case in all of them and
so
i um
want to encourage
all of them to to be i guess as as you
said kind of like a shining example that
this is where we we want you to be
involved right in the in your parents
learning and
and
it would be hard to achieve greatness
for those that are good outcomes for
those kids if you are not involved kind
of a thing that's i think the general
gist of the the bill so yeah thank you
follow up please
sure
um
so after the policies are made they then
go to the superintendents and they have
superintendent meetings with all of the
superintendents throughout the state
and then they're all approved
and so
i'm just concerned that
we're sort of double dipping you know
it's sort of
you know mom says no dad says yes
it just feels a little uncomfortable if
most of the most of the districts that
i'm familiar with do do that and by law
it says you know
it's like a parent
statement you have to notify the parents
blah blah blah blah
so if we do this this i feel like
we're sort of overstepping
the educational
standard
i can't think of
a word but
does it make sense what i'm saying to
you no it does not i didn't think it
would
i i mean i have a question um
in what you just said as far as um
you were coming up with the policies at
the local level and then they were
adopted at the state level as far as
like governing all of them oh no no no
okay
sorry that's
that's what i was i was worried about so
you were um because it seemed like you
were saying
uh the state level has this this
overarching policy and then we're making
the local levels have their own separate
policy and that's where the double
dipping happen
and so
but if that's not the case then yeah i
just uh the local level can have their
their different differing policies based
on the the needs of that community and
that would be completely in alignment
with this bill i believe so thank you
okay
representative altschiller
thank you madam chair
um
i would like to
i would like to discuss
page two of the amendment lines 11
through 15.
and then
reserve
another question for page 4 line
and 19.
so first page 2
of the amendment lines 11 through 15 an
employee of the state any of its
political subdivisions
including without limitation
any school board school district or
school administrative unit or any other
governmental entity who encourages
or coerces or attempts to encourage or
coerce
a minor child to withhold information
from his or her parent who is not
suspected of a criminal offense against
the minor
and sharing the information would not
impede an investigation of a criminal
offense against the minor may be
subjected
subject subject to disciplinary action
so i read that and red flags went up for
me um
right out of the gate we have
we know that um
schools are a place where children have
some real consistency
and they have some influential adults in
their lives
and
that when
children are
struggling
with
personal issues
that safe space to
talk sometimes is outside the scope of
their family
and
[Music]
i'm curious
and i want to know what protections in
that paragraph
allow for a child
who is
thinking about
sharing
their sexual identity
with their parents
but fear
that that will not be well received
and
have a conversation with a trusted
teacher
a trusted
librarian
we're very fortunate in our district to
have some incredible
teen librarians
for whom
many children find a space of confidence
and
place to
you know exercise some thoughts
[Music]
and if the parent
subsequently learns
that
their child
had a conversation with that other
trusted adult and that trusted adult
didn't immediately
tell that tell the parent thus breaking
the trust of the child
it looks like
a parent could bring that trusted adult
to court
as of page four
can we answer that question first right
it's all together that
a violation of the page 2 lines 11
through 15
in the
in the example i gave would result
in violations and criminal
charges on page 4 line 7
and also 19.
representative yo keller would you like
to respond
thank you i don't i don't uh
believe that
um
the representative statement is
reflective of
of the bill
um
there
there is no
requirement that the person
tell the parent that they reached out to
the kid
or that or the kid reached out to them
about anything this only says
that when they seek guidance from that
trusted adult
the adult shouldn't say well just don't
tell your parents
may i follow up
yes
so
we're we're in this um we're in this
bill is there protection for that
teacher
when that parent
who um is not necessarily um
feeling as magnanimous as you are right
now and says what do you mean
you told
mr jenkins that
you wanted to
you know
talk to talk to us about your sexual
identity what do you mean they knew
before i did
did why why do they know before i did so
under this law i can go to the superior
court and file a claim saying that
um
that mr jenkins encouraged my child to
be quiet and now it's mr jenkins
responsibility to
to
protect himself against a claim that
may or may not be true how do you prove
that a child
who is now feeling very very
persecuted which is probably why they
went to a teacher or a trusted librarian
or a trusted coach or another trusted
adult to share some information and this
is outside the scope of a criminal
investigation and if that parent is
angry we have given them a space
to press charges to have a
disciplinary um
letter added to a personnel file to
possibly be um subject to being guilty
of a class b misdemeanor
this really really puts a chilling
effect on teachers coaches parents
librarians
to
develop those interpersonal
relationships with children
that
encourages
growth
you know this is this representative i
find this chilling uh
and you're entitled to your feelings but
uh in this
uh bill uh section two uh line 11
through
16 it only discusses
if that person encourages or coerce
coerces or attempts to encourage it
doesn't
say anything about if the child goes to
that person in confidence
if that person says well don't tell your
parents or
anything to that effect then the
misdemeanor would take place i think
that
unfortunately we tend to be a legit
litigious society and if the parents
want to sue they
they have every legal right to sue but
that has nothing to do with this bill
thank you for your
questions i i i have i have another one
if if i may
one more thank you we have children um
that are are currently
in emergency departments going through
acute psych psychiatric crises
and
a significant number of those acute
psychiatric crises are from rejection
of parents accepting their gender
identity
and this
that has nothing to do with this bill i
would say uh respectfully madam chair i
would say that this opens us this closes
a space for
for exactly the kind of trusted adults
that we try to cultivate in our
communities
for children to be able to go to and
this
this tells all of those trusted
potentially trusted adults that it would
be safer for them
to shut that down and to not do that
because they could
be written up
for
a disciplinary violation or possibly be
guilty of a class b misdemeanor and that
this this is not in the best interest of
children this is in the best interest of
parents who
feel that they are
they
they're out of control and i
thank you for your thought-provoking
comments representative
i we do appreciate them
any further discussion representative
long thank you madam chair so a couple
things the fact that uh and courage and
coerce
from a coach that told
one of my players that um
told me that they tried
marijuana um
and i didn't get to the parents quick
enough
as a parent i'm gonna be upset and i'm
gonna i'm gonna tell
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell the coach that
yeah i think you told him to keep it
between us you know why would he go
would he go to you and not me so this
isn't this is encouraging that
and the bottom line is i think
i think i think this is all about
election
i mean whomever is in these school
districts that aren't giving out this
information it's a matter of an election
you need to vote them out and put people
in
that are complying with what the law
already requires with public information
so it's an election process it's a
warrant article not a
not a statutory fix because i don't
believe this is going to fix anything
and it's going to create more of an
issue with courts and within committee
thank you any further discussion
representative levesque
so on
page two lines one through three
it talks about the
parents right to enroll them into
any type of school public
or private religious
that's already into statute with rsa
1931 the parent already has a right to
choose how their
child is taught whether that's
religiously or
you know i
grew up in a town where we got to
choose which high school we got to go to
because
my school district did not have a high
school built in town and so we got to
choose whether to go to
one school or another or we had a chance
for three you know in those
types of school districts the parents
always have the right to choose which
school their child goes to
how they're taught
you know it's up to the parents so
that's already into statute
thank you representative petrino
thank you very much madam chair and and
thank you representative levesque for
your comment because i was actually
thinking uh the same thing
i was a high school teacher for 40 years
and i can tell you that as a matter of
state law
uh department of education policy and
school district policies most of what's
in this bill already exists
and it's it's redundant
if it's not happening it's happening on
some occasions not enough to justify
state legislation it really is a matter
of
those parents who have grievances
going to the school and then going to
the superintendent and then to the
school board and if they're not happy
with what's going on then vote them out
i can tell you in my town of milford
right now there's a lot of contention
going on and there are a lot of people
who actually have come forward and
they're running for school board because
they want to make changes in that school
district but what's happening in my
school district is not necessarily
happening in another school district
where things are going fine
and again i will tell you that most of
what's in this legislation already is a
matter of statute
new hampshire department of ed policy
and local school district policy and as
a teacher of 40 years i'll be honest
with you i supervised
a department and
most of the complaints that i got as a
department chair came from whether or
not a child's grade on a test was fair
or not because maybe the teacher graded
it wrong and you know you're being
unfair to my child most of the issues
that are here i never ever witnessed in
my 40 years this this bill really is not
necessary if there's a problem to be
fixed it needs to be fixed at the local
school level
thank you representative
any new information to come
representative
outshiller
thank you madam chair
on page 3
line 27
and 29.
and the center of page and the center of
line 27 if a parent is dissatisfied with
the results of such an appeal
or such an appeal does not take place in
a timely fashion as required by this
paragraph which is within 10 business
days the aggrieved parent may appeal the
matter to superior court with
jurisdiction over the applicable school
district
so now
when a parent is dissatisfied with the
answer
that um a trusted adult
was
providing a space for a child to
explore and and
explore the ways to talk about
something that's very personal to them
and then the parent
sends a letter to the superintendent
asking how did this happen why did this
happen and the parent is dissatisfied
with that report
now
the parent can take it to superior court
and i think we have learned over this
past two years that um it's that that
there are
a number of parents who have no problem
whatsoever
jumping into court um and i want to i
thank you i want to know i'm if if if i
may oh thank you
i was at a
i had the honor
of being part of a
boy scout
meeting in my town i have a really
really active
scouting community in the town of
stratham and i was working
this particular day with some scouts who
were
in fifth and sixth grade
and they were so engaged and we did uh
we did a mock hearing
like this and um with a chair and a vice
chair and a clerk and
people sitting here to witness
and
when we got to the end for the q and a
one of the scouts
said representative alcheler
what are you doing in concord
for the trans kids
and the other students the other scouts
did this
and for them that's a silent way of
saying yeah i agree with you yes i want
to ask that question too
yes
please i want to know the answer
and um
and so you know i talked about a few
things
but right now
this is what we can do for those kids
is this a this is not a
bill that is a
this is not a bill that is um
a bill of rights
for children
and this space on page two lines eleven
through fifteen
um doesn't help children it actually
creates spaces that can hurt them we
have children in new hampshire who have
been placed outside of our state in
psychiatric facilities
specifically
because of gender identity
their parents
have placed them in facilities outside
of our state because
because we say that
the trans kids
are perfect they're our kids
and in no way should we be making space
to create
conflict for those children so for
for my scouts this one's for you
i will not support
this legislation
thank you
representative belanger
thank you madam chair for recognizing me
to speak on the matter i think it's
important to recognize that
to the previous speaker's point this
doesn't mention anything about
trans or trans rights or
anything along those lines what it does
mention
is parental rights
and
parental rights and education
as a parent
and i believe and as i stated to my
community as well when we had this issue
presented
by a former member of this committee
that
a child's
issue
of being
transgender or not and i'm not saying
that is an issue for the record in case
anybody wants to grab any mic clips
if if they have this scenario and they
need to go through that process they
have that right to go through that
process i am not disagreeing with that
but it is the parents right that they
should be informed
in a joint
collective agreement to sit down and
communicate and chat because i as a
parent should never be left out of the
decision that someone else is making for
my under age child and with that i
conclude my comments
thank you representative
i'll take one more and then i'm going to
move the question
um
madam chair representative smith if you
have every right not to take my question
um
you as chair are in control so if you
would rather i not say anything you
should just say that
that's not my intent
representative because i respect your
right as chair i i particularly want to
um
commend my very dear friend
representative rice for asking
christina dyer to prepare
this document that was just handed out
to us i don't know if members of the
committee had a chance to see this
before today
but it is superb it is in
as usual as and i expect that kind of
work from committee researchers
it's very well done and i go through
every
section of 1431 as introduced
and there on the right
is the documentation referred to
by a number of our colleagues
that says this is already in
in
state and federal constitution in state
and federal law
and uh and then also as we know since we
believe in local control
in in
at least we say we believe in local
control whether we do or not um
in
in local school districts so that seems
to me
that
it is at least redundant
if not
almost insulting
to deny the existence
of all of this language
that already exists and
therefore it is very hard for me to
figure out
exactly
what the purpose
of this legislation
is
given that all this really exists
unless we want to make a statement
and i'm just not sure that legislation
should be used to make statements and i
again thank you for the courtesy of
letting me speak and i want to
commend both uh
representative rice
and the committee researcher for this
excellent work thank you thank you for
your comments
with that i will
ask
our clerk to call the roll
on the amendment
nelson
yes representative belanger yes
representative healey yes
representative greene yes representative
denise smith
representative long no representative
alessia
representative marjorie smith no
representative levesque
no representative chase no
representative
represent
representative petrino i will be voting
no
madam chair desimone
yes
eight to seven
thank you representative joe keller do
you have a motion yes i move uh otpa
and is that seconded
madam chair i second the motion
seconded by representative belanger
representative
yo keller would you like to speak to
that motion
i
believe enough has been said already
thank you very much thank you very much
representative yokela
any further discussion i think we've
done well
i will
when he's ready i will ask the clerk to
call the role
thank you madam chair
representative yokela
yes representative renzolo
representative nelson yes representative
belanger yes representative healy yes
representative greene yes representative
denise smith
representative long no
representative eliseo
representative marjorie smith no
representative levesque no
representative chase no
representative
no
representative petrino i will be voting
no madam chair desimone
yes
eight to seven
thank you at this time i'd like to take
a five minute break so people can
oh yes will there be a minority report
representative long and your motion will
be
you're awesome
uh thank you there will be a minority
report
and we'll take a five minute break to
stretch our legs or
just please come back in about five
minutes
in your instances
six
if
just
gave you that language
or like brought the case of guardianship
do you see what i mean
i'm not sure
foreign
so for you to move back to your seats
and
for the other people to get back from
wherever they went too
thank you all for coming back so quickly
i encourage you all to please take your
seats so that we can begin
um the next bill uh house bill 1518
relative to the requirements for
appointed guardians
and i'm going to ask
representative belanger if he has a
motion
i do madam chair thank you i
moved ought to pass
do i hear a second
i second
representative nelson seconds
representative belanger do you would you
like to speak to your motion
i do i have um
an amendment and i and i'd like to move
amendment 2022-0892h
and i would like to speak to my
amendment
certainly
oh
representative nelson seconds that i'm
sorry i didn't say that
you should have it
representative
i handed them out before
i had 15 so
go ahead representative belanger uh
thank you madam chair so it was a little
bit longer um this amendment than i was
kind of uh
alluding to but one of the things that
was brought up during the first part of
our first year session as i brought
forward another bill was that during the
guardianship and adopt uh prior to the
adoption process there's no visit being
done in a home
so
as promised i brought forward this bill
and this is what you see before you
today so
um
the guardianship statues and
appointments go under rsa 169c and rsa
463. this requires that after the
appointment within 60 days
the the guardian the guardians shall
receive a home visit by a child care
agency now this is any agency that is
approved by the department of health and
human services and licensed by them to
do such visits like home assessments
during the adoption process and very
similar in that instance
um
the home visit and this is where i'm um
i was hesitant to add this but i think
this is this is good as some parents um
may agree to to the guardianship that um
you may have the um
and this is so
the home visit may be waived if the
parents
give consent of the guardianship which
means they if they agree to the
guardianship and are not contesting it
now
in
the adoption
rsa you may ask for a waiver of the home
assessment and this is what my previous
bill had done to reduce the
the restrictions on that so
there's still the ability to allow for
the um
visit to be waived uh the cost
of the agency visit shall be paid for by
the guardian
um the agency sell
visit within 30
after within 30 days excuse me issue a
report to the court and the guardian
indicating the home is a safe
environment for the minor child
or if unsafe lists the unsafe issue or
issues to be corrected
proof of the corrected issues shall be
submitted by the guardian to the court
and the agency within 30 days
if the guardian fails to remedy safety
issues as referenced in sub-paragraph b
the agency shall promptly notify the
court and the guardian for appropriate
judicial action
failure failure
with this section without good cause
shown shall be grounds for judicial
review so i think this is just
as simply put
a brief
our visit from an agency
max
you know minimal cost um to this just to
ensure that um kiddos are placed in a
safe home and you know knives aren't
left on the counter
there aren't holes in the floor
it's not
an unsafe living environment it's not
an inhabitable place to live so simple
as that and um
uh yeah that's it
thank you uh representative smith you
have a question
i do thank you very much i have a
question for the sponsor um
uh
the where it says that the guardian
must pay
for the visit um
that's i just am
concerned about what happens if we
really if they're good guardians we you
know we really want
the children would be in and because the
concern is the children the children
will be in much better shape in this
particular arrangement than other
alternatives
but an
unspecific cost might be more
than the guardian
could bear and there's nothing in here
that indicates the ability to pay
and
i'm just wondering if that's going to
get in the way of a of a placement in
the best interest of the child can you
reassure me
absolutely so the home assessment of
during the adoption process is eleven
hundred dollars and most agencies have a
waiver
that allow you to or excuse me a grant
that allow if you're a relative
placement or provider that you can ask
for that grant and it applies and you no
longer have to pay for that luckily i
was i fell under that grant so we didn't
have to pay that eleven hundred dollars
um i cannot speak to the agency
or agencies as to what that cost will be
but i do not expect to see an 1100 price
tag for a brief report on whether a home
is safe or not in discussions with those
agencies
representative chase
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question it says here that a
guardian shall file a report with the
courts on behalf
with the courts before each review date
you and is this going to be something
that is going to be found say on the
judicial um
website that it's an actual report that
you fill out or is it just notes hey
here's what we did and
what what exactly is the report that the
guardian has to file
the bill i'm i'm not following can you
kind of
reiterate
please
what line are you discussing
representatives i'm sorry because you
amended the bill replacing section one
never mind
thank you
any further discussion
representative long
so
my ques my question is is on the grants
uh
i know waypoint doesn't it's a thousand
dollars um and they do have grants
however they run out of grant money
early
because that's what people are going for
first
uh and this is
this is requiring which i agree every
every home should be safe and
there ought to be a home
a home uh a home safety visit um but
i'm still
battling with uh
the cost to whom
and when it's waived is there a cost to
is there a cost at all
so
the waiver is on the agencies
it's to do the waiver
okay it's not so who does pay
if a judge waves it
who who pays
the agency does it for free is that it
yeah it is okay so um
when the
uh
home visit is waived um this is done at
the judicial branch or so
that
that's that piece um
if it's waived there's no cost because
it's been waived you don't have to do it
it's not a requirement
um
and
if it's waived it's no longer
requirements so they're not paying for
it in the first place so i think that
answers your question right i get that
yep follow up for me
follow up uh so it says uh on 21 the
home safety visit may be waived if the
parent or parents give consent
is it parent or parent
well so now as we know in this committee
not every situation and scenario is the
same sometimes you may not be able to
find said second parent which is why it
says parent or parents so if a mom and
dad agree then
that's fine
but if you can't find dad and dad's not
at the hearing
and mom agrees
there's no reason why
one parent can't speak for the other
parent if the other parent decides they
don't want to show up for a guardianship
hearing that they may lose guardianship
of their child
you follow up
follow it so the scenario is if what if
they're both there but they don't agree
one wants a wave and one doesn't
it doesn't yeah it doesn't say shao it
says may um and if
if they're both there and one of the
parents agree then they're contesting
the guardianship itself they're not
contesting the home visit which is a
different scenario in and of itself
which means the waiver wouldn't apply in
the first place okay
but i'm thinking on the uh
follow-up i make
absolutely thank you i'm thinking on the
parental bill of rights that may goes
into a shell
so
if i'm being yeah if i'm being fair
those are two different bills and we're
talking about this one here i i kind of
get where you're going with that but um
in the event that one or both parents
were there
in
um in in a in a ref one of the
references that we had suggested was
that when parents are giving
guardianship to grandparents or aunt and
uncles
and they're agreeing to the guardianship
um that's where the waiver
shall may right excuse me may be waived
that the parent or parents are agreeing
that this is the safe environment this
is a place where the kiddos should go
and we agree to that
but if they're contesting as
representative long had suggested
one or both they're not contesting the
visit they're contesting the
guardianship and in its entirety and
that is a different issue and that's
what the you know
that would be done
if they're contesting the guardianship
that's done prior to the guardianship
being put in place
okay thank you
thank you any further discussion
representative chase
thank you again uh and i
did find that area it wasn't taken out
of part one it's still in your amendment
if you look at nine li i mean uh line
nine it says the guardian shall file a
report with the court um on or before
each review date a parent may file a
statement or report with the court on or
before each review date
so my question again is what is this
report where is it found i was a
guardian for my daughter for seven years
i had enough things i had to file and
look at to be her guardian so i'm
curious what this is what does it entail
and
does it have to be done this says
could be reviewed every 6 12 or 24
months so are you expecting a guardian
to fill out this report and forward it
to the
judicial branch i would imagine
or finding the file there and then
having to do that three times a year if
it's requested the only thing that's
being changed uh in the
current statute is the bold print
what you're reading is in the current
current law
and we're not looking to change that
does that answer your question
i do understand what you're saying um
i just wasn't aware of that part of it
but my daughter also wasn't a minor
right okay
you're welcome madam chair if i may just
briefly absolutely thank you so um
my
my guardianship was for a minor and you
do have to fill out a six-month report
and it's just a basic simple it's
currently done right now in statute
we're not changing that as the chair
alluded to
every 6 12 and 24 months and
that's just to make sure that everything
is going hunky-dory right that's it
um and like i said it's already in the
current statue um
and that's just to make sure the
guardians are doing what they're
supposed to and being guardians of a
child that's that is a minor um and i
don't think it would apply to your case
because this is strictly for this rsa
and if your child if your child wasn't a
minor then that wouldn't apply to that
specific rsa in the first place
thank you anymore
discussion
seeing none i'd like the clerk to call
the roll on the amendment please
representative yokela yes
representative renzullo
representative nelson yes representative
belanger yes representative healey yes
representative greene yes
representative denise smith
representative long yes
representative alicea
representative marjorie smith yes
representative levesque yes
representative chase yes representative
altschuler
yes
representative petrino i will be voting
madam chair desimone
yes
15-0
representative belinda do you have a
motion i move on to pass as amended and
we have a second
a second
seconded by representative nelson
any discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
yokela yes
representative nelson
yes representative belanger yes
representative healy
yes representative green
yes
representatives denise smith
representative long no
representative alessia
representative marjorie smith
no
representative levesque
no representative chase
representative
nope
representative petrino i will be voting
no
madame
representative renzullo
okay
and madame chair just simone
yes
eight to seven
minority report
representative long
there'll be no minority report
do you want to do consent
the numbers are too close yeah
okay so
yeah
thank you
i love the fact that i'm able to rely on
the more
seasoned
representatives
actually madam chair what i was going to
say at the end of this but i'll say now
in light of your comment
is that i would like to congratulate you
if this is the first time that you have
chaired a committee
it's the first time that you realize how
many
bits and pieces have to be in the air at
the same time and you've done a
wonderful job
why thank you very much i
i really appreciate that
that said let's hope i do just as well
on the next two bills
oh thank you
um
it seems that the clerk looks like he's
ready for the next bill so
if it was here it was passed out i don't
see it
representative smith
i've just been tested
i hope i passed the test
the
amendment that the
sponsor of the next bill
has not reached us as of yet
so we're having that printed so that you
can all go over it
and in the interim we'll go on to the
next bill
it is an amendment by the sponsor
and one of the committee members will
make the motion to accept these
the amendment
no it's
i think it's one line
i thought amendments had to come from
within the committee
it was not
it won't be introduced by the sponsor it
would be introduced by
it was only drafted by the sponsor
it's not just one line
today
or tomorrow and i don't want to come
back tomorrow for one bill
i am
okay can we come to order please
yes
so we have a spleen desimone amendment
that i'd like you to look at
when when we opened this bill i just got
so excited
um
so
okay
we'll now open
uh house bill 1612
relative to the confidentiality of
reports
made to the division of children youth
and families and requiring guardians
that leiden be appointed
in certain instances
uh representative ryokela would you like
to make a motion i make a motion of otp
and is that seconded
second
seconded by representative belanger and
representative yokela would you like to
speak to your motion yes i'd like to
move uh amendment
2022-0
[Music]
h
and is that seconded
second representative belanger
and everybody should have a copy
of the amendment
it looks like this that's not it it was
just passed out
they had they might have more on that
they might have more over there
representative smith
they're on the far end thank you
okay so do you want me to speak to it
representative yokela would you like to
speak to the amendment
sure um the amendment uh
removes the gal issue which
um
was weird to be added in the first place
and
then it also changes
the um
requirement
that the um
reports be
could only be made if they they gave
their name address and phone number to
uh
um that the reports
may include that information and it also
allows
the department may inform the
complainant that um
there should there
that
complaints made maliciously or with
intent to harm
could be subject to criminal or some
civil penalties
and and also addresses the
court's concerns as far as the effective
date
thank you any discussion or do you just
need more time to digest
uh representative else
thank you madam chair
um i would like to reiterate some
information that we all received on
monday the 21st
at 7 19 p.m from the new hampshire
coalition against domestic and sexual
violence
and on page two of that for those who
have not reviewed it
as a reminder
often victims who are trapped in a
domestic violence situation make
anonymous reports to dcyf against their
abuser
whom they have witnessed inflicting
abuse upon their children in fact there
are many reasons that victim parents may
be afraid to report abuse or engage with
child protection service workers
victims may fear that cpsws will tell
their partner or
that what they say will get back to
their abuser that they will be blamed or
not believed or that their children will
be taken away the ability to make
anonymous reports
ensures that they can get the help they
need without placing their safety at
further risk it also alleviates the
barriers that victims need to overcome
to get support
that's correct and that's what this
amendment speaks to is the fact that
anybody who calls does have the
opportunity to make their call anonymous
what i am
what what is not anonymous is that
the reports
may include the name address or phone
number of the person making their
reports so their now
is
well they may but if the person is
anonymous
representative then they're anonymous
and there'll be no name
to put in the report
being
with respect madam chair being able to
make reports safely to dcyf regarding
suspected or known child abuse
is an important part of responding to
and assisting families escape violence
and abusive situations opening a door
for a possible
disclosure of name address or phone
number
is
again is
a chilling way to
put another barrier in front of victims
of domestic violence
i agree with you representative that it
is chilling
it is absolutely unnecessary
in some cases and that's why the
amendment removes
the fact that a person would be required
to give their name phone number address
or any other identifying information
the original bill
required it but not the amendment
and we're speaking to the amendment i am
speaking to the amendment on line 20 of
the amendment
the department may inform the
complainant
that should the complaint be made
maliciously or with intent to harm the
complainant may be subject
to criminal and civil civil penalties
that is correct and that would only be
in the case that the particular person
gave
voluntarily their name
if you don't give your name
there's no way to know who you are
with respect madam chair that's
that's not how the system actually works
in real life so
they think that this this
this sets up a barrier for
people trying to access family violence
prevention specialists in our state and
i
this
amendment
does not address those issues thank you
any other
information
representative belanger
uh thank you madam chair for recognizing
me and i just want to point out
that um
i spoke with the bill's sponsor about my
concerns about the initial bill in the
first place and i am very happy that
this amendment uh has come forward i
think um one of the things that i said
was uh it should be it shouldn't be a
requirement to have to
provide but that you should and i think
that's what this bill does so um
it says the reports made to the
department may include the name address
it doesn't say it has to it doesn't say
it shall it says it may um
and but and the department may inform
the individual that if you are
doing this on purpose um to be malicious
right as it says um that you are subject
to criminal and civil penalties i mean
as somebody who has made reports um to
dcyf i think this is a major step in the
right direction um
and uh i support the ought to pass
motion
thank you representative um i spoke with
uh
the director joe ripsom yesterday
concerning the amendment uh he was not
on board with
the bill itself but
he said that the amendment made it
exactly what it should be and he
supported the amendment
and therefore supported
the otpa motion
so
i feel very comfortable with that
representative long
thank you madam chairs uh so in essence
this has given dcyf the latitude
of asking for a name on her on a
complaint
uh is that correct
well
sure absolutely we already have that now
but it also gives the opportunity for
the caller to say i choose not to give
my name right without repercussions okay
thank you can i follow up on that one
certainly so what i'm thinking is that
down the road dcyf is going to know
what complaints
that they want
to complain it because they're thinking
maybe it's going to be false or maybe
this person has done this before
and it was a false complaint
well i i can't answer to how a person
who takes the call is going to think
no it wasn't a question
okay thank you
i'm just thinking i i'm
i'm thinking out loud
i do that a lot um
so
yeah i mean this be nice to ask mr
ripson if
it would be nice to have him here to
you know because i
i mean i
it does give him the authority to
ask a complainant uh
for their identification that that's
that's clear and i'm okay with that
because they probably get a lot of calls
from the same people and they can
recognize the voice and they could ask
that
can you give me your name
and by the way false information could
you you could be liable
um but i'm but i'm trying to
i'm trying to you know i i don't know if
that's good practice for dcyf to
um
with confidentiality
it appears to be working i mean yeah
people are putting in false claims
that's what's happening so this is
looking to fix that
and i'm not sure if this does
um i and
but i i lean without having mr ribson
here i i lean towards
thinking that this is um
putting a strangle on the
confidentiality reporting
because if i call in and i want to be
confident i want to be caught financial
and
i'm being asked uh can you give me your
name well i'd like to be confidential
okay we're not taking your complaint so
yeah i i i just have too many uh
i'm
thank you um this amendment doesn't uh
well it was my understanding in from the
testimony
from dhhs that they actually
encourage people to give information so
that they can follow up because the
person doing the investigation isn't the
person answering the phone and so they
want to be able to get more information
when they're doing the investigation and
have more more time to investigate so
they
prefer people to
give that information and not do it
anonymously do it confidentially and
um so there is
um already a practice of trying to get
that information so that that the
investigator could follow up and so this
is not this is um the proposed bill
proposed to change that and this
amendment is going back to the may
uh
may collect that information option
and
it that that is currently practiced
and so
um
there
[Music]
is when we get to the rest of the bill
um that is not changed by this amendment
uh
the the the um i think some of the
concerns as far as releasing the names
of confidentiality will is is addressed
in the um
the actual bill and not a subject of
this amendment so i don't want to speak
to it because that would be not not
allowed but i think that um
that
this is completely allowing for
anonymous reporting confidential
reporting just as as um
is the practice now so this
is more pulling back this the the um
the step for the gal and the requirement
that it own that eliminated the conf the
anonymous reporting and so it's pulling
back those and still leaving the rest of
the bill
in place and so um i think that is
the goal of this amendment so thank you
thank you
representative
petrino thank you i'll be honest i'm a
little confused because if i'm going to
call dcyf and give a false report
and then the person on the other end of
the phone says to me
would you like to
give your name and address sir
i'm going to say no
so i don't know why we need this
because
it doesn't make any sense
thank you representative al tiller
thank you very much madam chair
in the state of new hampshire everybody
over the age of 18
is a mandated reporter for any suspicion
of child
child abuse or neglect
every person over the age of 18
is a mandatory reporter and we have
created an environment in new hampshire
that is unique from other states
to be able
to get help to children
when they are experiencing abuse or
neglect and one of the things that has
helped us is being able to make
anonymous reports because
we know
that
retaliation for making reports is a
significant fear
for
family members who may be witnessing
abuse within their family it's a
significant barrier and fear for
neighbors
who want to make a report but genuinely
fear retaliation from their neighbors
and um
putting
changing our statute
that
instead of it being child first it's now
becoming reporter first or
possible abuser first
i think is unnecessary first of all and
actually hurtful
we know that when a report comes in
that
a child protection worker is dispatched
to do a minimal facts interview
and during that minimal facts interview
some of this information can be gleaned
if
if as a neighbor i make a report and i
want to make an anonymous report because
i genuinely fear retaliation from my
neighbor and
the librarian makes a report
and a teacher makes a report
that's three reports and we have been
encouraging that kind of activism in the
state of new hampshire to help
children and we aren't even getting to
all of them because our child advocacy
centers are absolutely overwhelmed
with
these forensic interviews for children
that are being abused and neglected we
can't get to all these kids we don't
we don't have enough people right now
and we're now putting in a barrier for
people to be able to make that report um
if there is an impression that you will
have to leave your name or that perhaps
if you don't leave your name your
your report will not be
handled with the same seriousness that
another report is
then
we're we're we're slowing down and we
are silencing
the very people we need to speak up um i
having just seen this
amendment
less than 10 minutes ago
i think that it
it creates an environment where people
will believe that it's a default to give
the name and that is not what we want in
this state at all we want as many people
as possible to speak out on behalf of
children
thank you
any further representative long
thank you madam chair i'll be quick
i'm wondering what my liability will be
if i
am mandatory to report so i called to
report they asked me for my name and i
say i'd rather be confidential
so they're not going to take my report
i'm assuming right is that what this
says
no that's not what it says
is ever going to say that you're a dumb
person
quite the opposite representative
representative smith
thank you madam chair um i can only
speak to what happened to me when
my dcyf call went in
they gave their information and dcyf
would not give me the information on who
called i figured it out on my own but
they never told me any of the
information so yes you may give your
name you may give your name
but that doesn't mean that the person
that is
uh being complained about is gonna ever
know who called
they may figure it out like i did but
it's not a concrete
it didn't come from dcyf
thank you thank you representative
any further questions or comments
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the amendment
representative yokela yes
representative renzullo
representative nelson yes representative
belanger yes
representative healy yes representative
greene yes representative denise smith
representative long no representative
representative marjorie smith no
representative levesque
representative chase no
representative
no representative petrino i'll be voting
no
madam chair desimone yes
eight to seven
representative yo keller would you like
to make a motion uh
oh to pass as amended
would you like to speak to that oh let's
get a second
second madam chair seconded by
representative belanger would you like
to speak to your motion
representative yokela yes thank you um
as i alluded to um before the
um still inside this uh
bill as amended it does say that under
no circumstances shall the identity of a
complainant who makes a report of
suspected negli
abuse or neglect in good faith or
pursuant to rsa
uh 169c colon 9
be released and so speaking uh
so that is specifically stated the the
um
it should not be released um and will be
kept confidential
and
um
the rest of the bill is just um
the purpose of the bill mainly now that
it's amended just instead of
changing the
the
the require the ch change from anonymous
possible
to not anonymous possible now that that
is removed the only thing really that
this bill does is ensures
uh it adds
uh new hampshire to one of the states
that actually has a penalty
for for uh not doing
uh
a report in good faith and so
i believe that that is important even
though we're we're saying we're asking
them to do it in good faith um
having a pen a
rule that says that they shouldn't they
shouldn't be making false or suspect um
making false statements
um and that there's there's a penalty on
the books for that i think that is a
value and hopefully will
deter even those people that still have
the option to
make that false report anonymous and
just hope that no one investigates and
uh and finds out who they are
um
will be dissuaded from making those
false reports so thank you and i
i hope that everyone will support this
uh bill as amended thank you
thank you representative your keller
representative also you have a comment
or question
thank you madam chair i have a comment
with relation to um the vote we're about
to take sure
well i will
i would i would like to think that this
all is made in good faith to protect
people
um but i don't i don't see it i see it
actually being a deterrent for people to
make complaints because our statute says
anyone over the 18 who suspects
just suspects that there is child abuse
or neglect
is mandated to make a report and the
reason we do that is because one person
may see a little bit and another person
may see a little bit and altogether we
get a full picture
if we throw
this this
amendment in this
this bill
i think creates a barrier where people
will have to will really reconsider
whether they make a complaint or not
um because they will feel as if they
will have to have investigated and have
a
um provable conclusion to even make a
report and that's not the intention
that's not the intention of our child
reporting laws and and there is actually
while you can make an anonymous report
if a case goes to trial all that comes
out in discovery
all of that comes out in discovery so
this is this is setting up a barrier
like wait
before you go any further just so you
know
you might be prosecuted
um
criminally or civilly from making this
complaint
or for doing for giving this report
and with
one in three
women in new hampshire experiencing
sexual violence
and the majority nearly 80 percent of
them
before they turn 21
we don't need any barriers
any barriers
at all perceived or otherwise to report
child abuse
so um i think that this is
i think this is unnecessary and actually
will hurt the process
so i encourage my colleagues to vote no
and to not hamper the already very
difficult work that our department of
youth and families has to do
thank you any further discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
representative yokela yes representative
renzolo
representative nelson yes representative
belanger yes representative healey yes
representative green yes representative
denise smith representative long no
representative
representative smith marjorie smith no
representative uh
levesque no
representative chase no
representative
no representative petrino i'll be voting
no
madam chair desimone
yes
eight to seven
minority report
who
will there be a minority report
yes madam chair representative altrill
will you be preparing that
and your motion will be
my motion will be itl
thank you
the next bill will be
house bill
requiring the recording and storing of
digital video
in all state-funded juvenile detention
representative belanger do you have
emotion i sure do matt i'm sure i'm
emotional
i cut myself short i'm sorry i'm
emotional to pat
and do you have a second
i second
it's been motioned and seconded uh would
you like to speak to your motion
representative belanger
i do um just briefly so i did ask the
director yesterday when i spoke with him
um
if uh
what his stance was on this issue and he
did uh
agree
he supports this bill um
and uh i i ask that we support the ought
to pass motion
thank you
any discussion
representative altschuler thank you
madam chair
hello yeah there we go um
so on a line six
it says um
art lines four through six each facility
paid for in whole or in part with
general funds
um what about children who are being
detained
in other states
our children
well we don't have any we do we have
children who are being detained in
vermont we actually do
that was not the time we have children
being detained in florida representative
thank you madam chair for recognizing me
that um representative is factually
incorrect
um
the
um when there are no students at sysc
being held outside of new hampshire
vermont itself does not have
a
facility that is locked and or secure
vermont sends their students who are
secure and or detained to our facility
in manchester also known as sysc
this
is referring to juvenile detention
facilities
when you're referring to
beckett family of services
who may have out-of-state homes they are
not juvenile detention facilities
thank you
representative smith
thank you um very much madam chair um
when i read the
the bill um
it indicated that those uh cameras were
not to be every place they're only to be
in certain places
and i understand
and value the importance of privacy
excuse me please
but um
i have for
15 years
wanted to close
sununu center
because of the
rampant abuses that were taking place
there that were denied denied denied
denied
and am pleased that we might be moving
in the right direction there
but i
am concerned
about how we balance the right of
privacy
for the detainee
with our obligation to be sure
that the detainee is not being subjected
to inappropriate
behavior in a location in the facility
other than those specified in the bill
and can you
help me
see my way to vote
yes on this
representative yokel would you like to
respond yes thank you so
the um
in the in the bill it says that
um the
activity in all common areas shall be
recorded and
it said areas requiring
privacy pursuant to state and federal
law or regulation cell be exempt from
this recording
obligation so we're recording everywhere
that we're allowed to record
and so
um
if something is happening in those
places that we're not allowed to record
obviously
um that is still a concern but
it
would need to be addressed elsewhere
where and if that was then repealed then
this automatically would um be reflected
in this bill because they would be no
longer required by those state or
federal laws that those areas were
protected
representative long
thank you madam chair um yeah i i like
the concept of this i want to see it
work
but i question each facility paid for in
whole or in part with general funds
so that would be the manchester police
station would be required
when they're dealing with a child to
have a recording
um
i
i just
want to be clear on that correct because
it's it's because they do get some state
funding for different programs juvenile
and adults
so
and with respect to uh i i did ask the
question to representative uh edwards
uh and he did say that it was new
hampshire specific only but i didn't see
where
[Music]
um
you know because i'm thinking of a
mental health
secure setting we don't have
you know we we often run out of it
rooms here uh and they're sent elsewhere
they're they are detained
um
they are secured and detained
uh so but he did say that it was new
hampshire only i don't see
where it says new hampshire only in here
but i
i did ask him and he did say this is
specific to new hampshire only
so
representative yo caleb
thank you um
so mental health treatment uh
unless it's
um
is not
detaining
someone
um if they're if they're in need of
treatment and the reason
as was uh
expressed by the dhhs commissioner was
that there is no detention happening out
of state
um
so there is
uh that doesn't mean that people aren't
receiving services out of state but the
detention is not happening out of state
and so
it isn't specifically stated in the bill
that it's only new hampshire but it is
in practice because that's where our our
uh
detention our secured attention is
that it would only be in the state
right but if we
in the future contracted with someone to
do an out of state then we would need to
ensure that that
that they are
um
uh
capable of of
providing the protections that we're
trying to give
i believe in this in this statute
thank you follow up for second so so
your statement is saying that
the commissioner of dhhs
is saying that there is no one detained
out of state
that was his testimony the commissioner
i don't know
no it was the um
the dh
rips him
commissioner
representative also
thank you madam chair
so um i need to i need to clarify
because there's a lot of
there seems to be a little bit of a
miscommunication
we have children
who are out of state
we have children in massachusetts we
have children in vermont we have
children in florida we have children in
wisconsin who are all placed out of
state for
various reasons not the least of which
is that new hampshire cannot meet their
needs
when those children come in contact
with juvenile justice
in the state they are in
they're still our kids we're still
paying for them
and we cannot legislate what another
state does
with their juvenile justice procedures
and i fear
while i don't dislike the intent of this
bill as a matter of fact i think it's a
really great idea but what this
this does not
this will set us up for
parents
new hampshire parents whose children are
placed out of state
and then
have encounters with the juvenile
justice system of the state they're in
now parents are saying well it's a new
hampshire kid being paid for with new
hampshire money i want that recording
and we can't compel the state of
massachusetts to do that nor can we
compel wisconsin or florida or vermont
so
i i think that there's a big gap here
that is actually a problem in the making
and like i said
if this were
new hampshire specific i'm all about it
but it's not
and so we are opening a window for
a lot of problems um
not the least of which are the parents
who are very very and there are a lot of
them who are very upset that their
children are placed out of state they
want their kids in state and this
because we can't meet this statute
would actually end up giving them a
really good case for bringing them in
and we can't meet those kids needs right
now so i just want to put that out there
not against this bill
in its intention and i think it's made
when in good faith there's a big gap
thank you representative ukela
thank you uh for recognizing me and in
response to the previous speaker um it
says um each facility paid for in
whole or in part with general funds
from new hampshire so if just because um
you know maybe we have someone providing
services
at a facility that's not a detention
facility say if they get in trouble
and they get moved to another facility
that's a facility that we are not
paying for
with our general funds and so it would
not be covered under this law if you get
if you're in wisconsin and you're a kid
and you get arrested that doesn't mean
that new hampshire is paying
out of general funds to give money to
the jail that is
housing that that kid so i don't under i
think that there's
um
that the example that you gave is
not
um the example
uh or
i think it's a misunderstanding this
first sentence that the the facility has
to be paid for and whole or in part with
general funds so i'm not sure that that
case that you gave as an example would
actually um
be accurate under this bill thank you
thank you representative belanger
uh thank you madam chair for recognizing
me so i want to talk about two things
number one
we're talking about detention
not a group home
which are two completely different
entities
and so insinuating that we have students
detained
in juvenile detention centers
is factually incorrect
we do not
out of state we do not
detain
any new hampshire
under age 18 residents
out of state
they might be at a group home again
very different things so let's make sure
that we're providing factual information
detained is defined
by before
trial
committed
means that you have had a trial
a judge agrees that you did something
wrong and you are now committed to sysc
for example
we're talking about a detention center
we're getting hung up on a word here
keep that in mind
thank you
representative ellis alicia
thank you madam chair for
taking my question
i'm not hung up on a word
but i feel like i'm negative nancy
so the people that
representative also are i believe are
speaking of
that are out of state the children
they're they're not um named as
being detained it's generally for
treatment they use a different word so
that's the first thing so i know
factually she's not telling a story
because i house some of them
secondly
for me i really think it's a good idea
however
for example the sununu center
cameras can be everywhere but they can't
go in the in the bathrooms with the with
the children
where do things happen
that
there are no cameras
i mean it's like policemen wearing
cameras and then all of a sudden you see
blank oh wow what
happened oh they didn't turn their
camera on
so i think it may help in a lot of ways
because maybe
someone who's abusing someone doesn't
realize where all the cameras are but in
other ways
the persons that have taken the time
to figure out where all the camera
cameras are
are going to go to a place
where they're not going to be seen and
they can't be filmed
and that's really scary to me
and it's just like in the school schools
have cameras too but they don't have
them in the bathroom but a lot goes on
in the bathroom
every else
and if i may representative
yokela why are you giggling are you
giggling at something that i said
i'm i'm wondering if your your um
your
position is that you want cameras in the
bathroom
i did not
it seemed like you were implying that
that it was a problem that we weren't
going to be able to record in the
bathroom absolutely
representative long
so
with respect to um detention and
commitment
so we do have children
detained out of state
when they get arrested out of state
they're detained if they get arrested in
massachusetts they're detained in
massachusetts
okay now wait a minute let me finish
i sat here and listened to all of you
it's com we don't have anybody committed
in out-of-state facilities
in a secure out-of-state facility
so you know so so that's that's
i'm you know i'm not seeing in this uh
and i just today brought it to my mind
uh having that discussion
um
these are just detained miners
securely detained not committed miners
right is that am i confusing that
you're not confusing that representative
what this bill is saying is
if a miner is detained in the state of
new hampshire
facility that we pay for
we cannot control
what massachusetts laws are we cannot
control what any other state
is doing we can only control what we pay
for
and what happens in our state so i think
that's where the confusion may be
we do have
kids that are in facilities
out of state but they are not being
detained
in facilities
that we pay for
we're only talking about the kids that
are detained
here
in this state
and facilities that we pay for just does
that help you
okay
representative belanger
thank you madam chair
respectfully to representative long's
point
anyone who is sent or is in another
state
who is attending another facility or
treatment center they are not
detained
as again defined before the trial
you can't we can't detain
kids out of state it's why they go to
sysc
they're waiting for their hearing
there are no detained residents out of
state i just want to make that
abundantly clear
thank you representative keller
so
i think i understand representative
long's point in that if a person
that is paid for at a community or like
a group home out of state gets arrested
and they're detained in that state
they
it's potential
that
they
they are not going to be detained at the
group home that we pay for they're going
to be detained at whatever facilities
that they have and those facilities in
massachusetts or wisconsin are not paid
for by
by new hampshire
and so that would not fall under this
law because the very first part of this
law says each indiv
facility paid for in whole or in part
and so therefore
just because they are detained
does not mean that they are detained in
a facility that we pay for if they sent
it to us in new hampshire then it would
be a facility that we pay for but we're
not paying for the detention facilities
in maine
or massachusetts or any other state
right
okay thank you
any further discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
representative
yo keller yes
representative renzolo
representative nelson
yes representative belanger yes
representative healy yes representative
greene yes representative denise smith
yes
representative long yes
representative
alsa representative marjorie smith yes
representative levesque
no
representative chase yes excuse me yes
representative altschuler
no
representative petrino i will be voting
yes
madam chair testimony
yes okay
12 12 to 3.
for the most part our work is done i
want to thank all of you
for your indulgence
and i want to thank all of you for your
very uh
good comments
um it's brought a lot to light
it's uh
all of your comments are not falling on
deaf ears
we've listened to all
is anybody going to do a minority report
report for the last bill
no
um
it
it really is uh
a pleasure to work with so many
wonderful people
who have so many thoughts
that may be different from each other
but they're good thoughts
and uh thank you for working so hard
today
is there any side that you prefer more
as with my children i don't have a
favorite we will adjourn
you